the Veep picked for diversity is headed
back to University but does Kamala have
the clout to bring college kids out
Kamala Harris AKA princess cackleberry
from planet Google face
is embarking on a month-long College
Tour to mobilize young voters in eight
Battleground States
it's a great idea though now that Joe's
locked down voters over age 150.
yeah she hopes all those young minds are
impressionable enough to fall for her BS
hey they believe dudes could breastfeed
so why not her be president isn't it
weird that Biden keeps giving her all
these tasks and then you never hear from
her about them again
it's like when I'm always asking guy to
shave my back
and all I hear is crickets apparently he
taught the Crickets to hold tiny razors
keep reading Greg okay
of course on paper kamla made sense but
everything goes south when she starts
talking whenever she speaks in public
you can actually hear America's IQ drop
the only thing that goes up is stock in
barf bags
meanwhile she thinks it's a good time to
remind us she's a Heartbeat Away from
the presidency you know which is like
your tandem skydive instructor reminding
you he has explosive diarrhea
there's never a good time to hear that
roll it
let us also understand that every vice
president
every vice president
understands that when they take the oath
that they must be very clear about the
responsibility they may have
to take over the job of being president
I am no different
oh yes you are
you are a little different because all
those words you strain together don't
make any sense
look all previous VPS weren't a
Heartbeat Away from the presidency and
Joe does have a heartbeat it's just the
pulse that we can't find
but Tyrus you know what would make that
sound bite even better
let us also understand that every vice
president
every vice president
understands that when they take the O's
that they must be very clear about the
responsibility they may have
to take over the job of being president
and no different
[Applause]
Emily Emily I I said this on the five
but it Bears repeating because sometimes
some of the things I say are so amazing
right uh like the BP for the the job
description is supposed to be America's
insurance policy in case the president
croaks but she's actually Joe Biden's
insurance policy so he can stay in
because you can't bear to have her
become president
I feel like the the biggest would you
rather of all time the ultimate would
you rather is Jan and Marsha no fighting
fight that's the whole point
you kill yourself if either of them were
in office yes
are untenable
NBC news they conducted a poll for vice
president favorable favorability ratings
it was the lowest favorability ratings
in their entire history of Vice
President polls with her in June and yet
Democratic strategists are saying that
if Gavin Newsom puts his hat in the ring
who's also untenable but that would be
racist they say it would be
disrespectful they say that it would be
a slap in the face to someone who has
who has what I'm waiting to hear what
accomplishments she's made so now she's
going to tour colleges like she did with
Howard basketball team is is she going
to have the same success rate of of
getting the team back in order because
last time I checked they kicked her out
of the locker room because what she said
made no sense nothing she does makes
sense and nothing she does serves us and
that's the saddest part because the end
of the day she's easy to make fun of but
it's all of us who are losing but on on
to her defense when she was in the
locker room she didn't have a penis
hey you know well so we know
would you see her if she was in college
it sounds like a great movie it's a
great move yeah where is the safest
place to be a weird leftist College
it's like sending me to a gym and see if
I can recruit guys that want to lift
yeah we're gonna hang out
you know what I'm saying it's like send
tires to a wrestling match he'll make
friends there
so go to a place where they're all going
to vote for you anyways because you're
going to say things like safe spaces you
don't have to pay your student loan and
then you can everyone else is weird
anyways because most of the people that
answer you back
scream yeah
oh I hear you so you know
it's a win for her I'm being I watched
this whole interview
and I saw a little gangster yeah pop up
when they said if we saw the long
version because everything we had this
long version yeah but when the first
question was asked she was like yeah I'm
ready
I think she's this was the worst pairing
ever they've hated each other Joe puts
her in horrible positions but he's
getting so bad that if she can make it
through a ceremony yeah I'm good with it
at this point if you could just finish
the ceremony you know a man of the
Vietnam vet he's getting the most
precious most prestigious award and this
dude just walked off yeah
just walked off Kamala I'm sure would
have finished it yeah so in that aspect
yeah why not she would have said she
would have said Vietnam
Vietnam we're all going to Vietnam on a
school bus Vietnam
Vietnam Venom is Viet are we missing
something is she closetly underrated
well I just think watching her speak is
very interesting because she speaks very
slowly and there's these long pauses as
if she's thinking about what to say and
then you hear what comes out of her
mouth and you're like that's impossible
[Laughter]
you
you know she you clearly weren't
thinking about that because it's got no
connection to the other thing you just
said which is very important in any
sentence and I honestly I mean when
she's like it's like anyone like no he's
obviously the oldest president and he's
an old 80. not a young 80. so just
acknowledge that don't pretend like this
is the same thing everybody goes through
no everyone's you specifically this
question for a reason please act like
you don't know what that is exactly you
know I I'm assuming guy you must be
really excited because next fall you'll
be looking at colleges and uh
have have your parents uh taught sat you
down and warned you ahead of time of
what Tyrus was talking about about the
politics the ideology the group speak
I'm actually a sophomore so it's still
it's a year off but I'm excited I'm
really excited
um a couple issues here sending her to
college campuses even when Joe Biden is
making up a story about his life and
then bewildered wandering off stage he
is still less cringe than she is yeah
and cringe doesn't usually play well
with the youths the other thing the
other thing was with her is and I say
this absolutely sincerely I hope she has
as much success motivating young voters
as she has had with everything else
she's done
particularly as borders are like I'm
rooting for that I really am
and this is just a tip to the
Republicans they want to spend less
money in the campaign but still be very
effective the question from the CBS
anchor was are you prepared to be
commander-in-chief the answer was yes I
am if necessary that's a five second ad
not even a 30 second ad that's cheap and
that will work yeah you're absolutely
right you know you're pretty smart for a
sophomore
you in the dorms you know you can join a
sorority now
[Laughter]
oh you'll have to grow a real beard I
prefer frat Rose
chatting with Moby Dick and a mayor who
can't recognize chicks hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else